These two elements over here are called the lower quartile and guess what--the upper quartile.
And in fact this range in between the upper quartile minus the lower one is called the interquartile range.
So this range is the data we used to calculate things such as the
mean and data outside this range are the north.
This is a simple but often very effective outlier removal technique that gives results extremely
that often are attributed to things other than what you're trying to understand.
Obviously this works well because there's exactly 11 items in our data.
If there were only 10 items, you would've to shift this element around and you'll break a little bit
of the symmetry but that's not a big deal because most of the results are very large.
Now assuming it works for 11, give me the next number up that also works.